Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Before we begin, a huge shoutout to RuneFactory for the sponsor.
And for sponsoring me so I can check out their newest game, RuneFactory Guardians of Azuma!
This is actually my very first time playing a RuneFactory game.
I've never played a RuneFactory game before, but I've heard a lot about it.
As someone that has played a lot of their other farming games before, I have heard about RuneFactory.
This game I haven't tried yet.
So this will be my first time, first experience diving in on the whole series.
What I have heard, though, is that if you've never tried RuneFactory before, apparently their newest game, Guardians of Azuma, is very newbie-friendly compared to other RuneFactory games.
It's very streamlined, very beginner-friendly, especially if you've never played it before.
Which is me.
So I'm fully blind playthrough.
I just know that it's like farming and with RPG elements into it.
And this is the first time that they actually focused on a whole Japanese and Asian aesthetic for the franchise.
Well, yeah, apparently it's a very good jumping point into the series if you've never played it before.
And I'll be like, you know, I'll be like the first time experience for it, like the proof of that.
Because I've never played RuneFactory before.
So then going in not completely blind, I do know like, you know, of course, because I am sponsored.
I do know the background information about it, like the basics of it.
So just like a lot of like farming games, there are a lot of romantic interests, a lot of wise foos, a lot of husbandos.
So, um, apparently you can pick, I think, 16 different romance candidates in Azuma, which is the best part.
A lot of variety, a lot of choices.
So, we're gonna be here to pick our waifu slash husbando and whichever one we're gonna, we're gonna, we're gonna charm and romance so they'll live on the farm with us.
I'm not gonna be too greedy this time.
Uh, but like I said, huge shout out to RuneFactory for sponsoring me.
If you want to support the stream, if you want to support, um, if you want to support the game, please feel free to click on the link pinned in the chat or like in the description below.
It does help out a lot.
So yes, um, but like I said, um, um, this game is, uh, for the first time is heavily focused on like, uh, the, uh, Japanese aesthetic as well as design.
And, uh, there's like other, there's, you get to play as something called an Earth Dancer.
And there's a lot of new weapons and stuff.
So there's apparently the newest weapons are like bows and talisman.
But the RuneFactory, like veterans out there, you guys are like, oh my God, new weapons!
And a bow is like a gun.
So, so I might, I might try out the bow because a bow is like the medieval gun.
So like pew pew.
Um, and so you can also like rebuild entire villages and stuff.
So, you know, like you can, uh, crap, you know, you can like make your own town and rebuild things and start like building, putting buildings on.
Like, I don't like you, move out.
I feel like, you know, I want, you know what?
I want more restaurants in my village.
I want my entire village to just be bow shops and stuff like that.
So there's like a lot of customization that comes to it.
And, uh, the more buildings you place, the more your town, you know, becomes more lively and, uh, becomes like bigger and better.
Yeah.
We need more food.
I'm going to gentrify my village.
And, um, there's like a heavy focus on the farming aspect as well.
Like, as you know, it's like a combination of farming and RPG.
Uh, so I'm like super excited.
Uh, they apparently in the DLC, they added two new characters to romance.
And I believe, um, I hope I don't butcher their names.
But I believe their names are Tuelan and Pelika.
So there are like, if you buy the DLC, the Seasons of Love bundle DLC, you can charm, you can romance even more villagers.
Yay!
More variety!
That's my favorite part.
You can, that's, there's so much replayability, see?
There's so much replayability.
Every run, you romance a new villager.
Haha!
Create your own harem, you know?
Safe, this is like, safe file number one will be her.
Safe file number two will be him.
And then you can like, bounce between safe files with all your, all your husbandos and waifus.
Hahaha!
Anyway, as you didn't know, uh, Rune Factory, Guardians of Azuma, it has also like, Haha!
I don't think I can read that.
Has, has physical additions that are available now for, um, on the Switch for $59.99, or on the Switch 2 for $69.99.
So, if you want to buy it now, you can actually with a physical copy in.
Um, and it arrives on the, there's also like, the Earth Dancer edition, which arrives on June 20th.
And you will get like, a limited edition with like, a lot of, uh, I'm extra giggly because I'm hyped up on caffeine for the last couple of hours.
Um, hahaha!
So, um, the limited edition comes with a Woobly plush keychain, which is like, I believe their mascot.
Um, it's like their, the animal guide mascot.
And it comes with two to CD soundtrack.
A hundred and sixty page art book.
Oh my god, I love art books.
Uh, Sacred Fan with display stand.
And the additional DLC content.
Season of Love, which means you get more romantic choices.
Uh, Festive Attire.
And Dark Woobly.
And I, I believe, I don't know, I don't know who, what, who exactly is Dark Woobly.
But maybe because his name is Dark Woobly, I assume he's like, Woobly but evil.
Um, that's just my assumption.
Hahaha!
As well as like, Rune Factory 4 outfits and a useful item bundle.
Um, also apparently the Switch 2, oh he's not?
Wait, is he edgy Woobly then?
Is he emo Woobly?
Uh, the Switch 2 version does work on the original Nintendo Switch.
So, um, so, and it does come with an upgrade pack.
So your saves will, can transfer from the Switch to the Switch 2.
So you don't have to worry about that.
Anyway!
Let's get right into it!
Rune Factory time!
Okay, wait.
Rune, for real!
Rune!
Haha!
Now!
Rune Factory time!
Um, it's just them with their hair dyed black and shouts out!
Hahaha!
Doth Woobly!
You know you want Dark Woobly!
It's...
For show me what you look like.
Ooh!
I can be...
Okay.
Ah!
Okay, the girl is really cute.
Okay, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna say like, the two choices.
Also sound good.
Let me know if I should turn up the sound or not.
I'm gonna say...
The girl character...
Is a lot...
I'm sorry.
But the girl character...
Is a lot cuter.
Hahaha!
I'm sorry!
She just...
There's just something...
Yeah, her style is...
She just has...
More fashion.
Hahaha!
She's just a little more fashionable.
And I like...
I like looking at her.
Um, but...
I like to...
No!
Haha!
Sorry!
Hahaha!
It's not you!
Maybe it is a little bit you.
But...
Alright.
Not...
Doki.
Um...
Alright.
A file name.
Now, when were you born?
Uh...
Wait, what month is it?
Summer?
Autumn?
Oh!
Summer.
Guys, my birthday is soon, guys.
It is in a month.
I see.
How much of a challenge do you desire?
Focus on the plot while...
Hahaha!
Okay.
Let's do a balanced...
The intended experience, guys.
Alright.
Not Doki.
I was gonna say story mode.
Hahaha!
Yeah, my birthday is a month, guys!
I don't know.
She just has more, like, pizzazz about her.
And so...
Oh my god.
There's a...
That's a dragon.
That's two dragons.
Is that Dark Woobly?
Oh it is!
Wait!
I think that's Dark Woobly!
Cause that's...
That's...
That's normal Woobly!
I knew it!
I knew Dark Woobly was just...
What is it?
Was Woobly but evil.
Oh my god.
Fight!
My...
Haha!
This is my Woobly OC.
Dark Woobly.
I bring game up a little bit?
Yeah.
No problem.
Whoops.
Haha!
Give me a sec.
I'm just bringing up the game.
Haha!
Tactical pause!
Okay, there you go.
Tactical pause time!
Wait!
Don't!
Don't skip!
Oh, it is yin yang colors!
Wait!
You're right!
I like how they use the other main character as...
Uh...
As like...
The villain.
Confront the black dragon.
Brace the dazzling light.
Oh, that's me!
Ah!
Oh, it's not Doki versus Doki.
Haha!
The other one is Doki.
And I'm not Doki.
Just a dream.
Oh wait!
I don't have to...
I don't have to read!
Thank god!
Good morning!
Oh my god!
10 out of 10.
I don't have to read.
Also, I brought up the volume a little bit.
If you feel lost, use the escape to open camp menu and check the tutorials in your adventure log.
Okay!
Do you have any idea what time it is?
Okay, so there's the action...
The...
The fight mode of this.
Oh!
This is my home?
Alright, let's look at...
Alright, so...
I need to fix...
Mouse sensitivity.
I almost forgot about mouse sensitivity.
And here's the volume, sound guy.
Here's the volume.
You want to fix the sound...
Easier.
Alright, let me up the volume a little bit here.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Oh, I don't need to look at the license.
I definitely read that earlier.
Oh.
Okay, so that's where I woke up.
Wait, what happened here?
It's awfully...
No, I have to read!
Most likely because of the enormous hole in the roof.
Wait, who did that?
Wait a minute.
That's not...
That's not cool.
Oh my god, Meido!
Can I romance her?
Can I flirt with her?
Hiroa!
Is she my new waifu?
Is she waifu number one?
I'm sorry.
Now, hurry and wash up.
We'll have breakfast after we tidy the shrine.
More cleaning today?
I didn't realize you were such a neat freak.
Cleanliness is a daily routine.
Is she my maid?
Besides, those who don't work, don't eat.
I suppose.
Can I ask you to take care of the sweeping bin?
I paid you.
Wait, why am I sweeping?
Okay.
Wait a minute.
Oh, she's a lazy maid.
Fine.
Just cause you're cute.
I'll sweep for us.
I'm the maid's maid.
Never mind.
She's not gonna be my first waifu.
She made the first mistake.
Making me clean.
Has it really been that long?
Oh, wait.
Am I a freeloader?
Oh, I'm the problem.
Never mind.
Boy, did we start off with a bang.
Never mind, guys.
Apparently, I'm the...
Who would have thought I was the problem?
I'm just a freeloader.
Under a big hole in the roof.
Oh, I caused that and we never fixed it for half a year?
You must be someone really special.
I mean, I fucking lived.
Sorry.
I'm fr...
I'm sorry.
I freaking lived through that crash.
I better be special.
I...
I came down from the sky.
I'm a messenger from the dragon god or something.
Oh, please.
I doubt that.
Turkey, please.
Divine envoy, you're now.
I'm happy to have you.
Since so many villagers have moved out, it feels good welcoming a new neighbor for a change.
Wait, how many villagers moved out?
Am I the only person living here?
What did you do?
Thank you.
I'm glad to hear.
Yeah.
I'm the only person that lives here.
What did you do?
There's a...
It's a problem if I'm the only one here.
Where are...
What did you do to them?
Where are they?
So, who is the god of the shrine anyway?
Uh...
Good question.
Yeah.
All I know is that they're a dragon.
What?
What was their name again?
Aren't you a shrine maiden?
I think it's...
Mocha or something?
Okay.
I need to speak to your boss.
You don't know who you're worshipping?
Okay.
Guys, can we fix her?
Do you think...
Do you think we could fix her?
She is the boss.
Okay.
That doesn't...
Reassure me, chat.
Okay.
I got a plum branch.
Oh!
Oh, I can encrypt sacred treasure.
Okay.
The sacred treasure is like related to like the farm stuff around here too.
Why fix...
She doesn't even do her job!
What do you mean?
Could you please...
Could you please dance and recite the prayer?
My favorite type of shrine mate.
She doesn't know what she's even worshipping!
Prosper.
Yay!
Oh, that's how you save.
She's perfect.
Oh!
You like that?
Offer these humble words.
A dance for her, Doki.
Great god of the dragon shrine.
Mocha something.
May your divine glory shine forth.
And bless us all forever more.
Alright.
Oh, she likes my...
You want me to dance more for you, you know?
Perform the dance of bonds that save statues.
Establish a link with the divine dragon within.
Saving all...
Okay, so that's how you save your game.
Oh, okay.
Also, let me...
Let me increase the volume up just a little bit more.
Uh, alright.
I increased the volume a little bit.
Let me know that's better.
Alright.
Hello, I did my job.
Did you like it?
Perfect!
You always look so graceful when you dance.
Dance for me!
Yes!
Why a plum branch?
I wonder.
Wait, I just do her entire job.
I just noticed that.
The dragon god really likes plum blossoms for one.
I think it's also supposed to help you forge an eternal bond with them.
Okay.
Can it really do that?
Sis!
Oh!
Aw!
Aw, she's cute!
Okay, so the town of two...
The town of three people.
Aw, you sweetie.
Thanks!
And here you go!
Enjoy!
Yay!
Free food!
I do her job and all I get paid on is food.
Thank you so much.
Food and...
I guess food and housing.
Is she hungry too?
What?
Yeah, I'll just eat when she's not watching.
This is my paycheck, guys!
Guys!
This is my paycheck!
Have you eaten already at all?
Yep!
She can ask her sister for food.
She's a child!
Why...
Why is she asking me?!
Her sister is right there!
All I paid in is food!
And survival of the fittest!
Hello!
Good morning!
Oh, it's a village of four!
Okay!
That's a lot better!
Suzu!
I see you're a bright little ball of energy as always!
There's a good girl!
I'm the best girl!
She does not look like she's starving!
You can't gas like me!
Simple!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Now then!
Would you two come with me?
The IA will be leaving shortly!
And I thought you might like to see her off!
Okay!
Who's...
Alright!
I wanna know who she is!
She's so hungry!
Doki!
She just sees me as an easy mark!
Why is she asking me instead of a sister who's right there?
In fact!
Her sister is a bad person!
For not feeding her younger sister!
How am I the evil person when her sister's the evil one?
Yes!
Everyone's been so helpful!
Good!
Nearly 50 years have passed since the Celestial Collapse!
The Celestial Collapse?
What's that?
Our village once bustled with travelers from all over Azuma!
Now...
It's but a shadow of its former self!
Have you tried, like, tourism?
Ever since that disaster!
Plants and animals alike have lost their vigor!
Wait, what?
The land itself is starved!
Yeah, that tree does not look so hot!
Like, it's the summer!
And nothing is growing there!
Runes?
The source of all life!
Oh my gosh!
What happened to the runes?
Looks like it won't bloom this year either!
How tragic!
You mean...
A rune?
A factory of them?
Before the collapse...
It gave us gorgeous flowers every year!
It sounds like they could use a...
Rune factory!
That captivating sight earned us another moniker!
A village of ever-blooming flowers!
So I guess when this tree started dying, people started moving away because they're like, Wait...
This town doesn't even have flowers!
Do you really plan to cut it down?
Indeed!
Takumi's inspection revealed that the roots have already begun to rot!
Best to remove it before it falls!
No!
We can save it!
I can fix that tree!
I'll dance in front of it!
Don't worry!
I'll dance!
I'm afraid so!
Legend says that a very beautiful...
False advertisement!
No!
Not that any of us have laid eyes on her!
After all...
I was barely older than Suzu when this tree last bloomed!
Wait, that's how long it's been?!
Sakaki!
Why didn't you do anything?!
You're...
Oh crap!
You're so old now!
What?!
Hey, hey!
What's a...
Good question!
Hmm...
He did it!
It's what he's supposed to do!
It's been like...
50 plus years!
Not even 50!
70 plus years!
And now he decided to do something about it!
I don't even know what a...
What do you mean why I'm mean to her?
I don't even know!
You think I have Google back then?
And so our population drops again...
Oh, she's moving away too!
No!
From what I hear...
The rest of Azuma fares little better than our village.
I wish her well out there.
Is it cause he can't dance?
If you're listening, I hope you recover soon.
And when you do...
Please bless us with your beautiful flowers again!
Please!
Oh...
That does it!
I'll be the one to revitalize our village!
What are you gonna do, Iroha?
I'll convince plenty of customers to visit my tea shop...
And try the best Dango and Azuma!
Okay...
Those who will blame me for not feeding the child...
She literally owns a tea house with Dango.
How is that my fault?
Let me help!
Yeah!
Alright...
We got this!
With the power of tea houses...
I shall make this entire village just tea houses...
Oh, nice!
God!
Who put weed in the box?
I tired of only Dango...
What's wrong, Suzu?
Yeah, let's go...
Are you okay?
Can I ask a favor?
Go ahead.
Yeah.
So lately...
Whenever I play outside the village...
I keep seeing this really weird animal...
What is it?
Is it the Wubbly?
Weird...
How?
Oh my god!
It's Wubbly!
And just...
Oh my god!
We're gonna meet a real hero today, guys!
Will you help me look for it?
Pretty...
Alright...
Maybe not...
Okay...
I really wanna meet Wubbly...
If it was...
You're so lucky...
You're so lucky that's Wubbly...
Or I would have said no...
You're the best!
Yay!
Let me show you...
I'm not doing it for you...
I'm doing it for Wubbly...
Huh?
Suzu?
Alright...
Oh, I can run!
Okay, nice!
Alright, where's Wubbly?
Where is he?
I saw it around here yesterday...
Bright white...
And covered in fluff!
White fluff?
A wooly maybe?
Come this way!
Alright...
An orange destination marker...
Shows your current goal.
These markers appear on the mini-map...
In the top right corner of the screen.
Open the map from the camp menu...
For a wider overview of the area.
Alright, you can also open the map at any time...
With M.
Okay...
Oh, okay...
Oh, so this is the village!
And then you can see like...
I can purify...
I believe like the more I purify...
The more people will wanna move into my village.
I heard I can like...
Wait...
View a character's profile to check their likes...
Plus the bottom bonuses you can unlock by...
Oh my god!
Wait!
I can woo her!
Cause it's red!
I think...
I believe...
Oh!
Intimacy.
Nice.
Likes and dislikes.
Oh, I don't know anything about her yet.
Okay.
Not yet.
Unless...
Oh wait!
The village does have more people!
See?
Look at that!
Not everybody moved away.
Just watching over children.
Hello, sir!
Oh look!
See?
Look at this village!
Sorry about Suzu.
There's so many people here!
Hello.
I saw it here two days ago.
Wait two...
Super big horns?
Oh wait!
It is my dragon!
Horns?
That it can't be a wooly.
Wait!
His name was wooly the entire time?
Oh!
His name was wooly this entire time!
That's my nickname for him, guys.
That's my nickname.
Okay, Whooply is cute.
That's my...
Whooply the Wooly.
That's what I'm gonna call him.
Freaking Whooply Wobbly over here.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You've known her for six months and you only know her name.
There's no hope between you two.
Whooply the Wooly.
And then...
And then the dark Wooly is...
Dooply the...
Dooply the Wooly.
D for dark.
Flying rules out Buffamu.
I'm starting to think this is a monster I've never seen before.
Oh no, it's my dragon.
I can't find it anywhere.
Wooly.
Wooly and Dooply.
I believe you.
Do you want to keep looking?
Suzu!
Time to come inside!
Where is it?
Where is Wooly?
Itoha's calling me.
I better go home.
Even if I don't want to give up yet.
Wait.
Will you play with me again tomorrow?
Play?
I thought we were trying to find a Wooly.
Wooly's are serious business.
Yay!
See you then?
Alright.
Okay, time to rest.
Okay, I guess it's not.
I guess it's sleep time.
Sleep time!
Okay, nice.
I'm glad I can run.
Yay!
Alright, let's go back to sleeping.
We ain't playing around, child!
We must find Woobly the Wooly.
Oh, nice.
Yoink.
Stealing your herbs.
Alright.
Sleepy time!
Oh, wait.
What's in here?
You can change it to...
I can change it to...
Wait!
I can make it a beach episode!
Nice.
Alright.
It's beach episode time.
Sleepy restores your HP and RP.
Rune points.
Staying up too late makes you sleepy.
Gradually draining your HP before you finally fall unconscious.
Sleep in your bed before this happens.
Wait!
Are there any consequences to fe- Other than health-wise.
Uh.
Are there any consequences to, like, collapsing in the middle of nowhere?
Oh my god.
Wait.
I- Okay, to be fair, I sort of really like her main outfit more.
Like, not Doki's main outfit.
Oh my gosh, her main outfit's so cute too.
God damn it.
Ah!
Alright.
My clothes stay on.
I actually really like her.
I really like her main outfit.
Sleep.
Yeah.
My clothes stay on.
Hate me.
What?
Hello?
Hate me.
Please.
If you can hear my voice.
What is that?
Woobly?
The woolly?
Woobly, that you?
What are you doing outside?
I have five more minutes.
Wait, who are you?
Oh, Earth Dancer.
That's me.
To the gods.
Blessed Earth, mate.
Hear my plea.
Wait, is this Mako something?
Earth.
What?
A great shadow looms over this village.
Can I romance you?
My life force is all but spent.
Dancer, I bid you act in my stead.
Me?
I offer you my sacred treasure.
Wield its kamiwaza with your dance.
And bring salvation to this village.
I beg of you.
Oh, she likes my dancing.
Don't worry.
I shall dance so hard that the village will come back.
Oh, and then the tree is blooming in their vision.
That's like the...
The god tree.
I shall dance for you.
Oh, and that's the drum.
The sacred treasure.
Wooply!
The woolly!
Oh, wait, you're not a dragon.
Wait, are you like a sheep dragon?
Finally.
Morning.
Wait, you can fly?
Oh, you're so cute.
Who?
No.
What are you?
Whoa.
Was that called for?
Don't tell me you're...
Yeah, it is him!
It's the white dragon!
Why does he sound like just a guy?
Just a fella?
He's just a fella.
He's friend-shaped.
Desi, it's him!
Oh my god.
The Mihoshi Habaki?
I am the ivory one who soars the heavens.
Mokoshiro.
Moko.
Oh, it's Moko something!
That's the guy I've been dancing for.
Come on!
I'm not saying all that again.
Just call me whatever you want.
Mokoshiro.
Moko something.
I kind of like Woobly.
See, I told you, Woobly!
I knew it!
I was like, there's no way I was butchering his name.
It is Woobly!
Woobly!
Oh my god, I got gasolated by you guys.
Woobly the woody!
Woobly!
You don't like it?
It's... fine.
Whatever.
Listen, you and I have a much bigger fish to fry at the moment.
We've got to track down the black dragon.
Oh, Doobly!
Oh my god, we gotta find Doobly, Woobly!
What black dragon?
No way.
Please tell me you're pulling my leg.
Why else did I make you an earth dancer?
Because I'm cute.
And...
Earth dancer.
That's right.
Dance that drum.
But don't keep rage painting.
And this is that divine instrument from my dream.
I'm supposed to use it in some sort of dance.
Yeah.
That's what drums are for.
You remember now.
Great.
There you are.
That's me.
Do you see that floating a thing behind...
Beside me?
Or do I...
Or am I going crazy?
Some kind of shadowy monster...
Hello?
You're a...
Yay!
Beach episode!
But you're...
Do you not see...
The floating dragon next to me?
Oh.
Wait.
All right.
That's not weird, right?
Wait.
Am I going crazy?
Or is he...
Is he real?
Wait.
What am I...
Doobly!
Oh my god!
Wait.
How come he looks cooler than you, doobly?
He looks so much cooler.
If evil, why cool?
Wait.
There's a flying boat?
Oh, she's cute.
Oh, she's cute!
I like her.
Waifu number two.
See that?
See her?
That's my future wife.
Number two.
Wait.
What is her weakness?
Why is he sucking up the tree salt?
Yeah, they're trying to destroy the...
I mean, we were going to cut the tree anyway, so he's like...
He's basically doing it for free for us.
No, let him keep doing it.
We need to cut it down.
Oh, we did it!
We helped!
Whoa!
Wait, what are you?
Are you like a fox, girl?
Hello.
I fell from the sky and I lived.
So, do you see this floating guy next to me, too?
I don't think she sees him.
I...
Now...
Now I'm, like, doubting if he's real or not.
Apparently, she's, like, from...
...Factory 5?
Is this sheep real or am I crazy?
Guys, do you guys see him?
He's sort of floating beside me.
Oh my god.
Ooh.
He has a cute outfit, though.
Wait, why doesn't the other girl have a...
...cute intro like him?
Skip.
...traveling companion.
Hina.
The assistant archaeologist.
Ugh.
You keep saying it wrong.
Oh, Hina.
It's Hina.
Hina.
Pardon?
You always insist on calling me Mallow, no?
That's a nickname.
Doesn't count.
Yeah.
It's a cute nickname, too.
Yay!
Oh, she's so cute!
Oh.
See, that's how you do an intro, Mario.
At any rate, that black dragon...
How did you know its weakness?
Well,
um...
Hey!
Iroha, are you alright?
Are you okay?
You seem to be missing your clothes.
Yeah.
Suzu and I are fine.
But the sacred tree...
It's all right.
Maro.
Sakaki!
I went to Italian there.
Thanks to gods, you're safe.
What was that black dragon?
Why is she in a bikini?
Well, if you bought a DLC, you can put them all in swimsuit and have your own beach episode.
Forever and ever.
A beach episode that never ends.
To think it would descend upon our poor little village.
That dreadful creature has sown calamity across all the possible land.
It's always beach time.
They say...
Wait, no!
It spreads blight bloom spores.
That's not good.
Plants that absorb the land's runes.
No, not the runes!
Our land has been weakened enough already.
At this rate...
My thing's already dying!
We're still.
Our sacred tree was caught in the crossfire.
The damage is too great.
You're cutting it down?
Okay, we're gonna cut it down anyway.
We should not have stopped the dragon.
If we lose the tree...
No, don't cry!
We can grow another tree, Roa.
We have no choice, child.
That's to remove it before it harms someone.
Let's put Saka Q in the swimsuit.
Wait.
Hmm?
How do I explain this?
The tree god...
Spoke to...
How do I sound less crazy, guys?
The tree god spoke to me in my dreams?
Or...
Let me try something!
Guys, what do you think?
You know what?
I think if I say the tree talked to me...
I'd definitely sound less crazy.
Considering we disgust her, I can't say I'm surprised.
Oh, yes!
I knew it!
They believed me!
I knew I were so much...
I knew I'm not crazy!
Oh, now you guys see him?
Woobly!
You just ditched me, you jerk!
I can't fly very far like this, you know?
A talking woolly?
Woobly, if you know anything about this, please tell me.
You're a divine messenger, right?
Yeah!
We can fix this.
I want to save this village and its guardian deity.
What do we do?
How do we kill your brother, doobly?
Do it for the child.
I, the great Woobly, descendant of the Hoshihabaki, shall impart my wisdom unto you.
Wait, then why did they, like, ignore him at first?
Follow me!
Yay!
Oh my god, we're gonna start farming!
I think this is the farming aspect.
Come to think of it, you said the god gave you an instrument in your dream, right?
Right.
She asked me to save this village in her place.
It's time to farm!
Then it's time to put that thing to good use!
The god of spring oversees this village.
Her domain includes healing and mirth.
Okay.
Let's start by giving these blighted trees a healthy dose of cheer!
If I dance in front of the tree, they'll become happy!
That lets you use your rune points to perform the unique ability known as Kamiwaza.
Oh, it's one of the sacred treasures.
I mean, there's a lot of sacred treasures in this game.
It's time to dance.
Use a drum dance to heal or spur growth in plant life, as well as restore blighted land to its former glory.
All right.
It's time to dance.
Whoa!
That's it?
That's all it tastes?
Oh my god.
I'm such a good dancer.
Oh.
Already?
I got tired already?
Oh!
It was two dances!
Oh, nice.
Pickle tournament.
Uh...
Turnips.
Okay.
And go to the inventory to use your items.
Uh...
Oh, and you can naturally regenerate over time.
I was like...
What?
I just danced like twice.
How am I so eepy already?
Wait, no.
I still have...
Oh, wait.
I still have rune points.
Nice.
That's right.
I accept tips, trees.
I'll dance for you.
But I won't dance for free.
Clap!
Yay!
Did you like that?
Did you like my dance?
Oh.
Want me to dance for you?
Watch this.
Okay, wait.
I can still...
Oh, I can't.
I have to be next to a tree.
Alright.
I did it!
Wait, is that the tea house?
Inspect.
Oh, it's not open yet.
I'm thirsty.
I'm so thirsty.
Alright, let's head back.
I danced, guys.
Oh, I have to dance in front of this.
Watch this, guys.
With the power of dancing, I shall heal this tree.
I offer these humble words.
Great entity which dwells within this tree.
May your divine glory shine forth and bless us all forevermore.
What?
I did it!
Amazing!
I was like, burn her!
Witch!
It's just that easy.
Wait, I could have done this in the beginning.
It's just one difference.
Is that what I think it is?
I knew it.
The gods must have sent you to us for a reason.
I barely did anything.
Yeah, I just danced.
Let's hear some phrase...
Let's hear some phrase from the...
Not for free, though.
The end of the hour.
Yours truly.
And you are...
Yeah, I was here for six months.
I could have fixed this on day one.
I was so tired.
Nickname, Woobly!
Yay!
Woobly!
You both have my deepest gratitude for your tireless efforts.
Okay, this game is actually pretty fun.
Not gonna...
Oh my god, it's the goddess!
Wait, is she waifu number three?
Is that waifu number three?
Oh, she's cute, too.
Oh my god, she's very cute.
Within this tree, I preside over Azuma's springtime and merriment.
My followers call me the joyful elegance of spring.
Oh, Doki, she is wife number one.
She's my goddess.
I had no idea you truly resided within this tree.
You are forgiven, Sakaki.
You are forgiven.
I have seen how you felt how dearly you care for this village.
But were I in your position, I surely would have done the same.
You honor me too greatly.
Lord Woobby, Earth Dancer.
Allow me to thank you once again.
My sins have been forgiven.
Oh, that's the drum she gave me.
Also, if you guys want to check out the game, feel free to click the link in the chat in the description.
Let's help out a lot, and you can try the game yourself too.
Your drum dance should be more effective now.
Though I am a god, I lost much of my divine strength along with my runes.
Please, Earth Dancer.
She picked me, guys.
Me.
I am loyal to Earth Dancer though.
Okay.
But like, she's a goddess though.
And she picked me.
Out of all the villagers here in this town, she picked me.
And I don't even live here.
That's above my pay grade.
Wait, wait, will she...
Okay, wait, actually.
So my option is, as you wish.
Or...
That's above my pay grade.
I don't know.
I feel like we can negotiate something more.
I...
I wanted to know...
She'll know that I'm assertive, you know?
Don't ruin...
Wait, can I...
Can I ruin the round on like, day one?
I got to play hard again, chat.
If I play hard, like, you know...
Goddesses want challenges, guys.
Oh no, okay.
That's a God-given request.
She likes the challenge.
The thrill of the chase.
Please, save our village.
Please.
That's right.
I'm not sure how much I can do.
But I'll give it my best effort.
Day one fumble.
I want everyone to ask for my help.
Wow.
Boost my ego even more.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
Oh my god.
It went by so fast.
I need to turn auto off.
I thought he was gonna read everything up to me.
And then I realized he skipped.
I...
Unlocking nodes in a skill tree lets you learn new techniques and increase your stats.
Unlock nodes with experience points, which you can earn by performing a variety of different actions.
Unlock nodes in a skill tree.
So that's my drum.
To generate shock...
Oh, I can use this as an attack.
Yes.
Use that shockwave.
There's no way I sabotaged my route on day one.
There's no way.
We just met.
She likes the thrill of the chase, guys.
Goddesses and gods are so used to having things like being given to them.
So that me saying no will be like...
Oh, you're interesting.
Saying no to a goddess?
Oh.
So stop enemies in their tracks.
Press to increase.
Okay.
Right click is increase.
It's effect.
Wait, that's not what I want to use.
Oh.
Hey.
I want to use my drum.
What's this?
Oh.
Sorry.
Let me clean real quick.
Hello.
Wait, why are you crying?
Is it because I said no?
That's right.
Cry some more.
My.
Living a long life has its perks.
The legends about the buxom beauty certainly didn't exaggerate.
Uh-huh.
Whoa.
By the way.
That's my waifu.
Whoa.
Get up.
Get away from her.
That's my waifu.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I don't live here though.
Is that easy?
Everyone here knows you.
If you need any help...
Calm down.
Oh jeez.
I need you to assist you.
What do you say?
Oh my god.
I loved when you're...
Giving me a position of power?
Sign me up.
What you said, partner?
I see you're starting to remember your calling in life.
I wouldn't go that far.
Everyone is like three dudes and a sheep.
And you've taken a load off my shoulders.
Wait, he just wants...
Wait, I'm doing everybody's job.
First a shrine and now mayor of this village?
A village chief?
Oh my god.
That's a lot of responsibility.
I think the goddess would be like...
Ha ha.
You now...
Hello, goddess.
I'm the village chief now.
What do I get?
What is that?
Oh, that's like...
That's like the ancient hoe.
Proof that you're a true earth dancer.
A terra-tiller.
With this, you can till new fields.
Grow crops...
Yay, I can farm!
A terra-tiller is my sacred treasure.
The time to sell it.
Just like with Ulalaka's drum, you'll choose it from the list of sacred treasures in your inventory.
Don't call the Ulalaka ancient.
Wait, isn't that...
It's like...
Okay, Ulalaka's drum.
You'll choose it from the list of sacred treasures in your inventory.
Let's farm!
Okay.
Oh, now I can farm!
Yay!
Finally!
The real content is here.
Oh, I got a rock.
Okay.
Oh, she's gonna teach me how to...
Wait, wait, wait.
Before I...
Oh.
Hello.
Hello, goddess.
You look unhappy.
What's up?
Are you okay?
Long have I slept.
I never imagined that the village would fall in such hard times in my absence.
It's okay, Ulalaka.
Ulalaka, I'm here.
I would happily offer you my assistance.
If only I'd regained my divinity.
Oh, that means we gotta spend more time together, Ulalaka.
Without it, I'm powerless to help.
Don't worry.
I'll spend as many hours, days, weeks together with you so you can get your power back.
Sounds like a job for the new head honcho.
Pass me!
Guys.
We need to get the village back on its feet as soon as possible.
And I hate seeing Ulalaka so sad.
I can dance for you, Ulalaka.
Spoken like a true earth dancer.
I've already prepared everything you need.
So, let's hop to it.
Uh...
We gotta do something about this mess out here.
I know.
Let's clear out everything in a way that makes some farmland.
That'll give us a place to grow some great eats.
Two birds with one stone, yeah?
Alright.
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Equipping the Tear Tiller will switch you to the Village Builder Mode.
Allowing you to expand the village to dedicate development zone.
While the Tear Tiller equipped, you can...
With the Tear Tiller equipped, you can hold to remove any unneeded objects.
Okay.
Fields are but one type of Tear Tile.
If you want to grow crops, you'll need to place the Field Tiles first.
Remember that.
Alright, that's easy.
Okay.
I equipped it.
Okay, I can remove this.
Wait, we don't need any rocks here.
Wait.
There's already, like, stuff here.
Okay, I'm destroying the debris.
I did it!
That's that easy.
Did you see it?
I'm so strong!
Did you see how strong and reliable I was?
Alright, time to place the Fields.
After equipping the Tear Tiller, press Shift to bring up...
Not Shift.
It was a tab to bring up the building menu.
Here, select what you want placed and press F in the spot you want to place it.
Okay.
Alright.
And then I'll place it here.
Boop.
Wait, why is it not 4?
Yeah, I did it!
Did you see that, Olaka?
Did you see it?
And don't you think I'm so big and strong and reliable?
And that I can take care of you?
Alright!
Okay, we'll plant some seed next.
Alright, turnip seeds.
Let's plant those suckers.
Okay, use F to plant...
Oh yeah, that's easy.
Alright.
Building menu.
Plant time.
Boop.
The first step to green thumb, water.
Your fields daily.
Your seeds and crops won't grow without water.
Neglect them for too long and they might wither away.
I mean, I just need water every day.
Right?
That's usually how it goes.
Water.
Yeah!
Look at me.
I'm so reliable.
Now it's time for the harvest.
Wait, already?
Maybe not...
Yeah, I was gonna say it.
I'm pretty sure.
Plants don't grow in like 5 seconds.
See, as we only planted them.
But there is like turnips over there.
Wait, look at those turnips.
See the shriveled up ones?
And the others that are nearly ready to harvest?
Hey.
Maybe that drum dance of yours could revive the former.
And help the latter finish growing.
Wait, so it's okay if they die.
I can just revive them.
Oh my god.
Maybe I'm the god.
I can just let them die and revive it.
Over and over again.
Help your crops and trees grow faster.
That dance will only work on each target once per day though.
Yeah, see?
They'll never die.
Holy, they'll even produce seeds.
Alright.
It's time to play god.
Equip the drum.
Okay.
You like my dance?
Woo!
Yay!
Alright, let's harvest it.
Finally a doki-proof farming game.
Oh yeah, that's a nice haul.
And you got some seeds.
You'll get seeds when harvesting crops.
That's important info right there, so make sure you remember it.
Yes!
All we gotta do now is ship them!
Okay.
Wait, I wanna harvest all the turnips first.
Wait, I might as well like plant the other seeds too.
Uh...
How do I do this again?
Um...
Okay, there you go.
Building.
Yeah.
And then...
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
I have so much power.
I can bring back any of them from the dead.
Okay, and then that should be...
Wait, how do I...
Alright, nice.
Okay, put turnips in the shipping shed.
It's over here.
Uh...
Oh my god, 45?
That's so much money!
Any items placed in the shipping shed will be sold off automatically by the next morning.
Netting your profit.
This includes harvested crops.
That's so much money!
That's like more than 10.
Remember, toss anything you want to sell in here.
Once it ships, you'll earn a nice little profit.
Alright!
Let's keep this ball rolling!
Huh?
We're out of field tiles?
Already?
No sweat.
We'll make some ourselves.
Um...
First, we need the necessary materials.
Since I'm feeling extra generous...
I'll provide them just this once.
Leave it to me!
All you have to do is call me whenever you want to make tiles.
Okay.
Call Woobly to create the various Terran tiles you can use in Village Builder Mode.
You must have the Terran Tiller to equip.
Wait, how many can I get?
Oh, I got a path recipe!
Oh, you can have like...
Customization and stuff.
With the paths and stuff.
Okay.
How do I call Woobly?
Wait, let me dance for these plants real quick.
Yeah, plants?
You like that?
Whoa!
Yeah, you like that, plants?
Don't worry.
I'll dance for you too!
Okay.
Terran Tiller.
Oh, I call for him again?
Oh, call Woobly.
Oh, I forgot to water them.
Wait, give me a sec.
Let me water them real quick.
Building.
What?
No.
No!
Okay.
Wait, why can't...
Oh my god!
Woobly, please!
I want no water!
Wait, have I already watered them?
Or maybe I have watered it.
Oh, dancing automatically waters.
Oh, okay.
That's great.
Wait, I don't have to do any work.
I can just dance.
Oh my god!
All I have to do is dance!
Oh, just keep dancing and never stop.
I'll never have to work again.
Morning!
Let's get up and at it again!
What's up?
Okay, I need Terran Tiller.
So, which do you want to make?
Dancing solves all my problems.
Quires rich in nutrients.
Hey, I feel like...
I'm land free.
What should I get?
Oh, I need red soil.
Oh, I need red soil to make...
Oh, okay.
How many do I need?
Two.
I already have red soil.
I don't have to make that.
Alright.
Just keep dancing.
Never stop dancing.
Ah, a true masterpiece if I do say so myself.
Now just do everything I taught you thus far.
First, throw down a field tile and plant some seeds.
You don't have to harvest them this time.
Come on, let's plant more turnip seeds.
Okay, nice.
Let's plant it here.
Oh, I want to remove this though.
This would be my turnip field.
Alright.
Dance, Stokey.
Dance!
Alright.
And then...
God, I'm like missing one right here.
This...
Oh, that tilts me a little bit.
Just a little.
It's literally just one.
It's just right there.
That's what I'm talking about.
You've really got a knack for this.
Yay!
Oh my goodness.
Thank you so much, Earth Dancer.
Yes.
This might just be enough.
Oh my gosh.
She's getting...
She's getting stronger with every turnip I grow.
What's she doing?
Oh my god.
She leveled me up.
She loves me.
Oh my god.
She's obsessed with me.
Guys, I'm in.
I'm in, guys.
I feel like I just had a huge boost of energy.
Guys, I'm in.
Proof positive that her divinity's back.
Wow.
Thank you, Ulalaka.
I'm so in.
I have another request, Earth Dancer.
Yeah?
If you could spare the time, would you help me...
Of course!
As a village chief that just got nominated today by all the villagers.
So you know I'm very popular.
I'll do anything for you.
That would return my divinity.
Anything.
Even there.
As the new village chief, it would be my pleasure.
Yay!
My humble thanks.
I can't express how relieved I am to have an young dancer like you.
See?
Like me, guys.
Like me!
I'm so in.
As the village level increases, the god that watched over the village will regain the divinity and reward you a new blessing.
Speak to the gods when the village is ready to level up.
Alright, head to the dragon's trying to sleep.
Oh, it's sleep time?
What time is it now?
Okay, give me a sec.
I gotta dance.
Oh.
Oh no.
I'm so tired.
Wait, I just need like...
Don't worry.
It says gradually I'll get my RP back.
Come on.
I just need...
Oh my gosh.
Fine!
I'll water these plants like a peasant.
My thanks.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I can't believe I had to use my hands.
And it's not for dancing.
Hey!
No, I gotta save my food, guys.
You only carry a limited number of items after reaching your limit.
Any items you pick up will go straight to the storage box or the dragon's trying.
Wait, I wanna...
See?
Okay, can he...
Oh my god.
It will...
The beach...
No, you put clothes on.
The beach episode will never...
Oh, I actually like her main outfit more.
I'm sorry, guys.
Her main outfit is so cute.
Oh, guys.
It's so difficult because, like, her swimsuit's cute, too.
But her main outfit is also very...
Okay, I'm gonna do a swimsuit.
Alright.
Yeah, the main outfit is so cute.
Oh.
Oh, man.
It's so difficult.
Yeah.
Oh, their designs are...
Oh, my God, it's so cute.
I can't help it.
I really like the colors combination.
Alright.
Give me a sec, guys.
You know what?
I'm gonna go with my gut.
The never-ending beach episode.
Alright, let's save real quick.
Yeah, I really like both the default outfits and the swimsuit DLC.
They're both really, really cute.
I love the designs in this game.
Alright.
I'll sleep.
Oh, wait.
You're right.
I gotta...
I wanna check...
Check it out myself.
I gotta be sure I'm making the right choice, guys.
Collect some herbs.
Just some green grass.
I gotta be sure I'm making the right decision.
Oh, my God.
You need a...
Do you want me to chaperone you to the beach, ma'am?
My thanks.
Don't worry.
I'll guard you.
Alright, let's head to bed.
Chee-e-pee now.
Goodnight.
Uh, Carl, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're a stokey.
Will you bless us with a future stream of Mind's Eye?
Which...
What's Mind's Eye?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is that what...
Is that...
Oh, wait.
That's the newest game that came out.
I think I've heard about it.
Um...
Oh, yeah.
Do you want me to help you put sunscreen on?
Sunscreen on?
The sun is so bright.
We don't wanna...
We don't wanna hurt your delicate skin, goddess.
When you go to sleep, you'll receive a breakdown of your actions that day.
Each category will be tallied up and you'll earn cumulative amount of all-purpose experience points.
Use...
Oh, I can upgrade my skill tree.
I'm here to treat you like a goddess.
That you deserve.
Yeah.
Why don't we ask Sakaki if we can help with anything?
Oh, yeah.
He never really, like, told me what my duties are as village chief.
Hello?
What do you want me to do?
No, you've got to stop pushing yourself.
Can't you ask someone else to handle it for you?
Let me go, Iloha.
Wait, where is he going?
I may be old now, but I was once known as the demon one.
What?
You?
This is nothing for us.
Yeah, I was gonna say, demon what?
See?
What did I tell you?
Yeah, old man.
Go back to bed.
The real village chief is here.
Let me know how I can help.
Such a kind soul.
Our carpenter Takumi left a few days ago and hasn't come back.
Oh, wait.
No, our carpenter.
We only have one?
I thought I'd ask him to repair the dragon shrine since you're staying there.
It's been six months.
How long has he been missing, Sakagi?
Sakagi, how long has this man been missing?
The curse of old age.
Oh, I know.
Our new chief could look for Takumi.
What do you say?
I'm sorry, but now isn't a good time.
Okay, we do have to fix the hole in the roof.
Great.
I'm glad you're so reliable.
Certainly, I hope he's hard.
All right.
Yay, I'm reliable.
I have you on the search.
Takumi went looking for materials in the abandoned shrine to the north.
I'll ask the gatekeeper to open a way for you.
Oh, really?
Oh.
Before you go, take these with you.
It should be useful for gathering.
Oh, I got a hammer.
A cheap hammer.
Now that you have a hammer, you can mine or deposits to collect materials.
stone and ore.
Or deposits will spawn after a day.
Oh, and I got a tree cutter.
Now that you have a hatchet, you can chop wood to harvest lumber, saplings, and more.
You can only harvest from fully grown trees.
I know what tree is full.
Where's the gray tree?
Wait, can I get rid of this?
Wait, I'll dance.
Okay, dancing did nothing.
Oh, I can lock more nodes.
Oh, yeah.
Sacred tree ring.
Wait, do I have enough XP for it?
I suspect your waifu wouldn't be happy if you did that.
It's okay.
She's not here.
Oh, I found the tree, guys.
It's time.
Oh, she's ready.
Guys, she won't know.
Don't worry.
She won't know.
Spec, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Toki.
Thanks for playing Rune Factory.
I love the series and it's great seeing you get attention.
Hope everyone gives it a try.
My favorite is for it.
Have a good night.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
If you guys want to check it out, feel free to click on the link in the chat, in the pin in the chat and in the description.
I mean, it's been pretty fun so far.
I'm actually enjoying it.
And then we've only just like been in the beginning of the game.
Stop self-sabotaging your romance.
I can't help it.
When it's too good to be true, I have to, I have to self-sabotage.
Because I don't deserve love.
You were about to start searching for Takumi without a single Onigiri for the road.
You brought us some?
To Ria.
Nice.
Hey, why are you making us do the hard work?
I mean, I was planning to bring some when it suddenly hit me.
Look, she's a goddess, guys.
She has such high expectations.
What if I don't satisfy her expectations, guys?
I gotta end it before she realized I was not the right earth dancer.
Do you even know how to make Onigiri?
Yeah, it's like a donut.
Now that you mention it, no.
You've forgotten that, of all things?
Just like I thought, I've got the recipe and all the materials right here.
So give it a shot.
You can't fight on an empty stomach.
Oh, nice.
Aw, she's making food.
Aw, look at him.
He's like, oh my god.
She's gonna make me an Onigiri.
Okay, so I can make food at the teahouse.
Collect recipes to expand your cooking repertoire.
Cooking can restore HP and RP.
And grant temporary stat increases.
Okay, so they expire after a day.
Okay.
Nice.
Follow the recipe exactly.
Am I doing it right?
Yeah!
My stomach's rumbling like crazy.
I got Onigiri.
Not bad for someone who forgot how to make them.
I did it.
See?
I can cook.
Did you see that, Ulaka?
No kidding.
Though I'd argue that you had a great teacher.
I did it.
As a reward for mastering the way of the Onigiri, I'll give you extra ingredients to make more...
Yay!
Freeing food!
It's so simple.
You only need a bonfire to prepare them.
Oh, nice.
Give it a try if you find one.
Thank you for all the help, Iroha.
Good luck out there.
Bring back Takami in one piece.
Don't worry.
I will.
Do the pieces have to be attached?
All right.
Oh, I got Seam Race.
And Salt.
Oh, that's for my Onigiri.
All right.
This is the RPG element of it now.
Spring Highlands.
Oh, and there's like apparently a lot of different locations around Rune Factory to explore.
So this is like not the only area here.
Anesia Whale.
While the range isn't very impressive, they hit fast enough to keep enemies on the back.
But making it harder for them to strike back.
Okay.
Oh, free stuff.
Wait, how do I...
I want to cut this.
What's this?
Get a load of this blight.
Oh.
Wait, why am I sweeping the woods?
Oh, nice.
Someone...
Let me steal the Onigiri from the stride.
Oh, man.
I am such a good person.
Let me...
Wow.
What?
They're not gonna eat it.
It's a waste of good food.
Beware of oil.
What's this?
Look.
They're offering the Onigiri to me.
Oh, a treasure chest.
Can we just open it?
Surely no bad luck's gonna happen to me, right guys?
Why not?
It's practically begging for us to take a peek.
Yeah, I got a runin' hat.
New hat.
Want to try it on?
Oh, yeah.
The appearance option lets you adjust the looks of your equipment.
Changing the parameters or effects of what you've equipped.
Okay.
Yeah, new hat.
Here.
Appearance.
Wait, actually...
No, I like...
Okay, but I can have equipment.
So...
Oh, no.
Oh.
No, I can wear this, but it doesn't show up.
Oh, I like that.
So you can customize your...
Um...
You can customize your, like, um...
The appearance more.
I like that.
So you don't like the gear.
You don't have to have it on.
So it can be aesthetically pleasing.
That's right.
He was just...
Did you see him?
He shot me first, guys.
It was self-defense.
Guys.
It was self-defense, guys.
He ran at me first.
Yay.
I'm leveled up.
Oh, I can mine too.
I need this orb.
He was coming right at me.
I didn't want...
I didn't want it.
I didn't want to do it, guys.
What's this?
Oh, the bridge is out.
Did anyone leave an onigiri here?
Oh, Earth Dancer.
Your dance has brought me joy and happiness.
Congrats, dude.
Let me pursue you upon this recipe.
Oh.
Oh, I can make more turnip soup.
Ribbit?
Hmm?
What was that?
Huh?
Wait, who...
What's a kid doing outside the village?
I know.
A child.
Oh.
Hey, you there.
I saw you doing a weird dance.
Hey.
Ever heard of frog statues?
Yes.
Just who even are you?
Me?
I'm croaky.
People call me the frog statue fanatic.
Hey.
But more importantly, do you like frog statues?
Well, do you?
Croaky alternate universe.
I suppose.
Oh, I suppose so.
We like recipes they give us.
Yay!
Ribbit.
After many long years of struggle and solitude, I finally met Nutter Soul, who shares my hobbies.
Hmm.
Oh, you're way too young for that to be true.
As a matter of fact, I'm a huge frog statue fan.
Oh, well, the fanatic part of your name says it all.
Whoa!
Ribbit?
How did you know my name?
Oh, no.
Yeah, short-term memory loss.
I love him.
You mentioned it like 10 seconds ago.
Oh.
So, how can I not like them?
Those bulging eyes.
The cold, damp feel as you run your...
Okay.
That's...
Okay, croaky.
Everything about them fascinates me.
Uh, you okay?
By the way, I have a favorite to ask from...
Guys, I don't know this...
I don't know this kid, guys.
I...
Do not associate me with this child.
What is it?
And that would be...
Oh...
As a true statue fanatic, My duty is naturally to learn about every frog statue in Azuma.
Hmm...
I can't do that all myself.
No matter how much I wish I could.
I'm bound by the pain of my existence.
Curve...
He has parents?
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Okay.
Hmm...
I...
Honestly, I just assumed he was an orphan at that point.
I mean...
You're still a kid.
Ha ha ha ha!
My parents don't...
Do your parents know your...
You...
About your frog obsession?
Ha ha ha!
Say, it's way too dangerous.
So I sneak out instead.
We can't have that.
Oh, please don't.
Your parents have a point.
Yeah.
I know, I know.
I'll go straight home after this.
Hey!
What, can you let me know if I find any more frog statues?
Ha ha ha!
Tell me about their location and shape and size, feel, smell, taste, every...
Okay, okay!
I'm gonna be talking to your parents later.
Ha ha ha ha!
Wait, what was that last one?
Well...
Please, I'm begging you!
Understood.
Sure, okay.
I should not enable this child.
Ribbit, I knew I could count on you.
You can usually find me in Spring Village.
Let me know when you ever find a frog statue.
Oh...
Find it up and I'll give you some treasure I discovered.
Huh?
We should really talk to his parents, guys.
Ha ha ha ha!
Really?
Yeah.
Only makes sense to reward you for your work.
Ha ha ha!
After all, more frog statue means more happiness!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Okay...
You can do it!
Great!
Thanks a bunch!
Alright.
Perform it before one of many mysterious frog statues.
And the god residing with it will give you a recipe.
Yay!
I'll be able to cook more.
Wait, what's up in here?
Wait, is that another frog statue?
What's that?
Oh no, it's an ore.
Okay, we gotta do this.
Alright.
Nice.
Guys, don't...
Oh, shit!
Ha ha ha ha!
Sorry!
Don't...
Don't lick ran...
Oh, hi there!
Friendly?
Oh!
Not friendly!
Oh my god.
The chicken doodle.
A pleca doodle.
Guys...
It was not friendly.
No!
I accidentally used my drop!
Wait, I can still...
Okay.
Your dance has brought me joy and happiness.
Granted, allow me to bestow upon you this recipe!
Oh, I can make Tamago!
Nice!
Oh, there's...
Oh my gosh.
I actually swear I really want Tamago right now.
Oh, sweet rolled eggs recipe.
Ahhhh!
Hello, Tamago!
Hello!
I'm...
Oh, I'm craving it right now.
Oh, I should dance.
Dance!
Yay!
Alright, that's not...
I'm tired now.
No more dancing.
Okay, let's...
Alright, let's...
Let's get them out of the way first for free XP.
I like myself some free XP.
Oh, more ores!
Come on.
Oh, I can hold it.
Whoops.
I keep...
I skipped the instructions there.
Oh, look!
A chest!
Yoink!
Yay!
My soil!
So, what's your verdict?
Good or bad?
Alright.
Let's actually do our mission.
What's your...
Oh, fast travel!
Okay, nice.
So, there's fast travel here.
Don't worry.
I shall dance for the gods.
I do nothing.
Alright.
Let's save this real quick before we go into our next mission.
Our next cutscene.
That's a good question.
I think, like...
Because I'm still in the tutorial...
It doesn't...
I don't have the...
The in-game time hasn't passed yet.
I think that's why.
I think that's why it hasn't passed.
Yeah.
This dragon's not scared.
Oh, whoa, whoa, Woobly.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Stop projecting.
Hello?
Who's that?
He seems friendly.
He seems really friendly.
Okay, I can hold...
I was, like, clicking when I was mining.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
That's armor.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, I want to put armor on.
Yay!
Yeah, just...
What?
Wow, he can loiter if he wants.
This is a free village.
Alright, Pentrowazi.
Don't disappear until you...
Okay, that's easy.
I have lots of practice.
Okay.
That's right.
What you gonna do?
Hit me?
That's right.
You can't hit me.
I'm level three.
Nice.
Look at that.
I didn't get hit once.
Guys.
Alright.
Oh, I got an energy potion.
If I keep mashing, I'll never die.
I got miso soup.
Ooh.
Hello?
I mean, all I have to do is left click.
Yeah.
Sacred treasures aren't the only thing that gives you perks for mastering them.
Go to the short sword skill tree and unlock charge attack.
Battles should be a breeze if you keep unlocking more skills to choose from.
Wait.
I can even unlock...
Ooh.
Oh, I can have different attacks, too.
I like that.
Okay.
Yes.
How loud XP.
Hold and release.
Ooh.
More damage.
No.
We don't need defense if we just do damage.
We should be in a better shape now.
Did you know that drum dance can also help you in battle?
Yeah.
But it costs RP.
I want to save that for dancing.
I'm a dancer, not a fighter.
Well, restore HP to you and any nearby allies.
Drum...
The most difficult combo of all time.
Okay.
Doink.
More rock.
Yay.
And then more...
Oh, vinegar.
I like that.
Oh, wait.
Is that one hit?
Wait.
That's so strong.
Yes.
More vinegar for my salad.
Wait.
That's insane.
I assume that that's like a perfect attack, too.
When it glows.
That's like a crit or something.
Yay.
Level four.
More vinegar for my...
Oh, soy sauce.
Nice.
I need soy sauce for my sushi.
Come on.
For my sushi that you're always going to make me.
The tea house.
Oh, nice.
Yoink.
My offering now.
Earth dancer.
Your dance has brought me joy and happiness.
I got a grilled onigiri.
Nice.
For my onigiri that I found.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Where did that chicken come from?
Why is there a chicken here?
Okay.
Nice.
He's just like, hey, guys.
Where's my friends?
Bye, chicken.
Okay.
I like the charge attack.
Oh, I can harvest the trees?
Oh, yeah.
Because they're like grown trees.
No, I shouldn't.
You know what?
She's not here.
Guys, she's not here.
I can chop this tree.
Oh.
Oh, it stays.
I thought it actually cuts down.
Oh, the tree actually stays.
Okay.
That's like less bad.
Nice.
Guys, I knew that.
I knew that it stayed, guys.
That's right.
Nice.
Okay.
I like that this attack one shot.
It makes it much more convenient.
Oh, there's a nice statue.
Oh, nice.
I don't see no villager here.
Is it for free?
May these fresh fruits and vegetables grow ripe.
And one day.
And bring someone.
See?
It's like a communal.
No, I'm not a thief.
It's a communal.
It's a communal farm.
Look at that.
It's not my cabbages.
It's a community farm.
And I'm part of the community.
Dance.
I get...
Oh, a stone sculpture recipe.
More offerings for me.
I can use it for more offerings.
You'll think it's for a god.
But it's actually for me.
I also sense a human presence.
A human?
What's a human?
Oh, the carpenter.
I almost forgot about him.
I was gonna say, what is he doing here?
I forgot my main mission.
To find the carpenter.
Alright.
Is that miso?
What's this?
Oh, cheese.
Nice.
That's right.
Oh, a grill.
Do I need to eat anything, though?
Oh, the onigiri that I found at the shrine.
It was just sitting there for some reason.
My jar cheese.
Yay!
Dance here.
I mean, you were working for food for six months.
So, it makes sense.
Nepers, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
No, no, no.
I didn't steal it.
It was just lying there.
In the open.
You know, like, the five second rule?
It's already past five seconds, so it's mine now.
That's what it actually means.
Oh, nice.
That gives me my RP back.
I need that.
I had, like, no energy.
Oh, it's limited, though.
It doesn't fully heal it.
It's like...
It's like ocean law, but on land.
Land law!
You've got company!
Stay back!
Is he friendly?
Oh my god, do you see those abs?
Bosses of high defense will make it difficult to damage them through normal means.
So, one strategy is to fill up their sun gauge.
When the gauge is full, you'll immobilize them and deal more damage.
Each boss has a unique...
He's going through some things, okay, guys?
That poor emo horse.
Attacking them with their elemental arenas or striking their weak point will fill the gauge faster.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Drum tap.
I don't think he liked my drum.
Nice.
Oh.
Hey, nice.
I stun him.
Okay.
Nice.
No!
That's fine.
I stunned him again.
I'm just gonna use the... I'm just gonna use the crit here.
It's actually faster.
Oh my gosh, look, I dodged!
Oh my god.
Look at that.
Finally, I know how to dodge.
I learned.
I learned from my waifu.
Oh!
He heard no bell.
There was no bell.
Who's that?
Hey, see?
I told you he was a nice person.
Cyclone Blade?
Let me solo him.
I took him out in one hit.
Oh, that's so... Wait, what level are you?
Oh, that's the carpenter!
Is that Takumi the carpenter?
How did he become a monster?
Oh, wait, he became a monster?
Blame the blight.
I've seen it happen many a time.
When runes dry up, people fall more easily.
Oh, he was, like, possessed by the demons!
Um...
Thank you for helping us.
No thanks needed.
You've already done most of the work.
Why are you hiding your face?
Are you ashamed of yourself?
However...
That is not...
...convenient at all.
Oh, so he's, like, a sword master.
Swordsman seeking greatness.
The greatest swordsman of all time.
I have many questions for you.
But first, you must take this man to safety.
Okay, we'll take him back to our village.
He works for us.
Oh my god, his hair...
Whoa, who's that?
Dubli?
Okay, it's just...
I love the swimsuit costume.
Little?
Yeah.
It was all me, though, guys.
You, like...
I guess he did some stuff.
Like, he hit him once.
I'll repay you a hundredfold.
Say the word.
Will he do stuff for free?
Oh, yeah.
Gladly.
Huh?
Who's this fuzzball?
That's Woobly.
I am not a fuzzball.
For your information, I am a divine descendant.
Dearest Takumi, it's an honor to make your acquaintance.
I am the joyful elegance of spring.
Please, call me Ulalaka.
Ulalaka?
Well, aren't you a lovely young lady?
Hey, she's mine!
Hey, back off!
Actually, I've dwelled in this village...
...of self-defense again.
Come on, now.
I've lived here all my life, and I've never seen a girl half as pretty...
Hey!
Hey, I'm right...
Hey, hey!
I'm right here.
My, my.
You flatter me.
Stay away from her!
Whatever.
It's pretty?
Whoa!
Let me fill you in.
Oh, Sybil, thank you for the rain.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe it.
Wait, I'm the village chief.
I can kick him out of the village.
How long was he gone?
How...
What's up, Fluffy?
You meant what you said earlier, right?
I'm gonna raise his taxes.
What did I say?
That you'd repay us?
Yeah!
Leave the village!
Oh, yeah!
You bet.
Only fair for saving my life.
You just say the word, and I'll come running.
That better apply to me, too.
Saving you was a team effort, okay?
Woobly, you just stood there.
That's so.
Can't you humor me a little?
No.
My partner and I are gonna need your help later.
So don't forget you owe us.
All right.
What is he gonna do for me?
Would you come with me a moment?
What?
I'd like to give you something.
What is it?
Take this.
Consider it a...
I love freestyle.
Isn't this...
What is it?
It was my...
Oh, yeah.
Fix my roof.
Yeah.
I was gonna say.
Wait.
I need him to fix my roof.
I'm sure you'll make better use of it now.
Trusty partner?
Is it a sword?
It's the bow!
Yes!
There you go!
Apparently the bow is the newest...
One of the newest weapons for the...
Rune factory.
In Rune factory.
Oh.
Wait.
Practice bow?
That'll make for a good secondary.
Gun get.
Yeah.
A secondary weapon.
One you can switch up to on the fly.
Let's say you're wielding a sword when you suddenly feel like using a bow instead.
It's kind of like that.
I like how he's like...
This has been my trusty partner.
For years and years.
And it's like a practice bow.
Oh.
Okay.
All right.
Try it out yourself.
And you'll see.
All right.
Let's equip our practice bow.
Look.
There he says.
Practice bow.
I'm a little concerned, old man.
Okay.
How do I use the practice bow?
Uh.
You can also equip a...
Use Q to...
Oh, I can press Q.
Bow's fire.
Steady stream of arrows.
I can hit both distant and airborne enemies.
Use control to ready your bow.
And then...
To aim.
Then...
Okay.
Yeah, I can do that.
That's easy.
I wonder how to do crit for a bow.
Impressive.
I was right to put my faith in you.
I don't think it has dropped off.
Are you absolutely sure?
I think it's time.
You see, this recent incident with Takumi has forced me to seriously consider retirement.
Oh, I just read it faster than him.
I hate to ask for anything in return, but...
I'd like you to check the request board every so often.
The villagers will sometimes hang wooden emma plaques bearing their wishes.
I'm sure they'd appreciate your aid.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I'll be it.
I guess I'll consider it repayment for the bow.
Oh, he thinks I'm funny, guys.
Guys, it's not rude if he thinks it's funny.
I'll leave this village in your capable hands.
Yeah.
Go take a quick look at the request board.
It's your duty as both chief and earth dancer.
Don't worry.
I got you, guys.
Guys, he laughed.
I was...
I'm funny.
Villagers will write down wooden requests on the wooden emma plaques and hang them on the request board.
Make their wish come true and they will reward you.
Report back to the request board to finish shop.
Okay, so these are like my mini mission.
Where did he go?
Was he a ghost?
The village feels empty.
Well, many...
Wait, that's your own request.
Build a house in Spring Village.
Tune in request.
Turn in request.
Okay.
So this run down has so few houses available.
That's his own request.
Okay, so I need to go to the carpenter and the carpenter will make this for me.
Is that where he lives?
Okay, that is where he lives.
Oh, where's the clock?
Where is it?
Oh, I see it.
It's 12 p.m.
Lunchtime.
Okay, wait.
Okay, I should do this mission.
Gotcha.
That's what old Sakaki wants?
All right.
Who am I to say no?
Count me in.
Fiesta time, guys.
You're still injured though, right?
Bah.
Gotta put the muscles to work every now and then.
Or they'll forget everything I taught him.
The real problem is going to be getting materials.
Think you can handle that for me?
Leave it to me.
Of course.
Here.
Here's a blueprint for a house.
Or what we call a recipe.
Can't build without one of these.
Let me know when you've got all the materials we'll need.
Okay.
Just a humble house.
We need lumber and stone.
Okay, I need to start cutting trees down.
Buildings and decorations.
Finding recipes will further expand your construction options.
Only villagers with the hobby woodworker skill can run a carpenter.
We just need one anyway.
But let's go roll what we need just in case.
You can collect lumber from trees growing outside the village.
Wither lumber won't do us any good though.
You have to perform your drum dance to revive the tree first.
By the way, if you've got new samplings, you can plant them inside the village.
Once they're fully grown, you can gather lumber from them.
Just like trees out in the wild.
You can also mine material stone from ore deposits outside the village.
Trees and ore deposits replenish themselves.
So you can harvest them again the following day.
So you can't gather all you need in one day?
You can always come back the next.
And if it's money lacking, then it's time to grow and ship some vegetables.
Okay, that's easy.
Alright, so I revived a lot of trees back then.
Yeah, like this.
Wait, no.
Which one are the trees I revived?
Oh, wait.
Oh, it's on the mini-map.
I see it.
Okay, thank God.
There's a mini-map here.
I don't remember a little bit of where some of these trees are.
I've danced so much, guys.
You don't understand.
Man, all I did was dance.
I've lost track to how many times I've danced in front of all these trees.
I've danced so many.
Okay.
Yeah, there's like...
On the mini-map, it shows you, too.
What's this?
Oh, there's a big tree here.
Okay, nice.
How do I...
I want to, like, plant trees.
Oh, my God.
And then...
Oh, there it is.
Oh, wait.
Oh, how do I plant my trees?
Do I have...
Oh, I have to plant it here.
Oh, okay.
This is, like, the only place I can plant.
I was like, so...
I was like, what?
All right.
One tree.
Remove.
I want to remove this.
Okay, remove.
All right.
And then tree number two.
I need to line this.
Tree number two.
Tree number three.
And tree number four.
Tree number five.
There we go.
Do I need to water these?
I don't, right?
These trees aren't demanding for water, right?
No, they're fine.
All right, nice.
What's over here?
Oh, it's just, like, plants that I can grab.
Do I have enough?
Where's my wood?
Okay, I have 24...
Iron...
Wait.
How many rocks do I have?
Scrap metal.
Strong claw.
Onigiri.
Wait, how much rock do I...
Wait.
How do I know how much rock I have?
I don't know.
Oh, wait.
My drums.
I forgot about my drums.
Oh, one or three?
Wait, what's one or three?
Okay, wait.
Let's...
Oh, I forgot to water them.
Oh, whoops.
Stop.
Oh, no.
Drum time.
Ooh.
Yay.
Drum time.
All right.
Wait.
Did they not...
Did they grow?
Oh, wait.
They did.
Oh, I forgot to drum this.
Drum time.
Yay.
All right.
Wait.
Oh, they won until their harvest.
Okay.
Oh.
Wait.
These guys harvested, though.
All right.
Let's grab some turnips real fast.
So I can grab some money.
And then the...
And then the Ulalaka would be so happy.
She'll be so proud of me.
All right.
There's all my turnips.
Where are they?
Oh, there it is.
70...
Oh, my God.
70 turnips?
Okay.
That's a lot of turnips.
How do I know how much...
Oh.
Oh!
There you go.
Construction.
Oh, I need like 10 more.
Wait.
No.
I need 20 more.
Okay.
I need to find more rocks outside.
That's fine.
How do I go outside?
It's this way.
Wait.
How to go outside?
Oh, it's the other way.
Thank God there's a map.
I'm very directionally challenged.
All right.
Yay!
We're rich!
All right.
Wait.
I'll get some more rocks.
Is there any more Onyx offerings for me?
Oh,
sweep, sweep.
Nice.
See, I told you.
Those offerings were for me.
I'll just chop it just...
Just in advance.
Mine time.
Nice.
Was it material stone or just rock, guys?
Mine time.
Oh.
I'll just grab this real fast.
We don't need more...
We don't need more trees anyway.
So we'll leave these guys dead.
For now.
Material stone?
Okay.
So we're almost done.
I think after I chop this, it should be over.
Nice.
All right.
Let me double check.
Oh my god.
I just need one more.
I need one more rock.
I can't go over here, though.
Oh man.
I need...
I guess there might be some more back here.
Maybe?
Let's see.
There might be...
More rock back here.
Yeah, I'm looking...
Oh wait, there it is.
I see it.
Yeah, I didn't see that.
Where's all the rock?
It's like they tripped it all off.
There's no more rocks.
Wait.
Oh wait.
There's stuff up here.
I didn't get to loot this.
Because I defeated the boss.
Oh, there's a chicken.
I have unlimited arrows too.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's a lot of damage.
Oh, and there's like no...
I have unlimited arrows too.
That's nice.
I like that I have unlimited arrows.
Cannon.
Equipment.
Wait, what does that look like?
Nice.
I like unlimited arrows.
Okay, there we go.
That's the last thing I need in mind.
What'd you find, huh?
Got more material stone.
Oh, I can make a bench now too.
And then miso and soy sauce.
Yay, more food.
Wait, what's that?
Why is it...
Why does it look evil?
Why does that look evil?
Hello?
Are you evil?
Oh, relive the battle.
Oh, I'll be like...
Hey guys, did you see me?
We look so cool.
You guys want to see it again?
Alright, how do I fast travel?
Save.
Wait, how do I fast travel?
It says save or do nothing.
Oh, the map.
Oh, it's the map.
Oh, I see.
Warp.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, okay.
I want to warp back home.
Spring dragon shrine.
Okay, we gotta go to the construction area.
I like that.
I like the fast travel.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I don't mean to brag, but I...
Hey.
Alright.
Oh, construct building.
On shelves to castles.
Got all my stuff.
Wait, I just needed 10?
Oh, I can't read.
I...
That's okay.
That's alright.
That means I have plenty more for later.
Stand back and watch me work.
Guys, we learned that I still can't read, guys.
Now that you constructed a building...
Uh, place in your development stone and it will grant various effects called village bonuses.
Village bonuses don't just improve the village.
They boost your stats, too.
Now note that you can place the same building multiple times, but you'll only receive its village bonus.
Oh, I can't...
I can't just fill up my entire village with ramen shop?
What's the point?
In specific villages, so pay close attention to where you place them.
Oh, yeah.
So, yeah, guys.
There's more than one village, by the way.
And that's the best part.
So, that, like, encourages more exploration.
And more, uh, more explore...
Like, uh, more village managing.
That means I can be mayor of several other villages.
Oh, my God.
Do you think there's, like, goddesses in other villages?
All right.
Uh...
Here, Diller.
Let's see.
Place the house.
Uh...
Where can I place it?
Oh, back here.
Okay.
And then, building menu.
I want to build it right...
I don't want to build it, like, in...
In my garden.
So, I'll place it here.
Oh, my God.
My goddess harem.
The possibilities are endless.
I'll place it here.
Yay!
Oh, and I can move it, too.
If I don't like it.
I can move it, like, here.
Uh...
Mmm...
I'll put it here.
Just so it looks better.
So it doesn't look like it's just randomly there.
All right.
Turn...
Oh, yeah.
Turn in my plaque.
Press Z.
Oh, like the building thing?
Yay!
And I got money!
I did it!
Did you see that?
I made the village even better.
I need to reintroduce myself.
By the way...
Are you fond of music?
I would like to perform with an accomplished dancer such as just some time.
I am your chosen earth dancer that you ch-ch-ch-chose.
Let's chat.
Hooray!
Yes?
Oh, my God.
Just listen, guys, and you're in.
Reading a garden book left me a newfound appreciation for people's love of plants.
Yes?
We could talk even more.
Wait, how do I give gifts?
Oh, my bond with her grew!
Wait.
How do I...
How do I give her stuff?
Do you want to turn it?
I have turn it?
Oh!
Do you want...
Do you want cherry blossoms?
Hello!
It's kind of awkward introducing myself.
Anyway, come visit Susan and me at the tea shop whenever you like.
Oh, she can cook me stuff.
Oh, okay.
What is it?
And talk to her?
Days like this make me want to hold an open-air tea ceremony.
Doesn't sipping tea under a clear blue sky with a nice breeze sound amazing?
Oh, look at that!
That's all it takes, guys.
Just listen.
Oh, I should plant turnips again.
Oh, water.
Let's see.
Building.
I can plant cabbages!
Cabbages with my turnips.
I'm pretty sure the cabbages will give me more money, too.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
I have so many turnips.
And then...
Oh!
Wrong one.
Drum time!
Yeah!
No.
You don't matter to me.
You're not a waifu.
All right.
And then it's time...
Oh, I have to sleep?
I don't want to sleep.
There's so many people that want to talk to me.
Okay, but to progress, I need to sleep.
You're right.
Wait.
Does he have swimsuit?
Oh, he does.
Ha!
Wait, actually...
Ha ha!
He has a cat.
I like it.
Ha ha ha ha!
Yay!
My beach episode...
My never-ending beach episode.
I need penalties.
Combat 8.
Yay!
I got all that XP.
It's okay.
I can revive them with my...
With my dancing.
Isn't tomorrow Murasame's birthday?
You should get a present that really wows him.
Wait, but we just met.
My present is his...
Ha ha!
I already got him a present.
It's his swimsuit.
Ha ha ha ha!
Isn't that enough of a gift on its own?
Yes!
I should...
I should farm a little bit of the trees.
I think this game is like...
This game is pretty relaxing.
Oh, it gets like lumber.
Does it not give cherry blossoms?
Oh, so like...
My regular trees doesn't give cherry blossoms.
I see.
It's very relaxing.
But you guys want to check out the game.
Click on the link on the chat in the description.
My cabbages!
Oh, I thought it was ready.
I was going to be like...
Yay!
Look at them grow!
Yeah, it's very relaxing.
I do like farming games.
I play...
I tend to play farming games off stream if I just want to relax.
Okay, let's...
I'll send that and the cabbages too.
Yay!
I'm rich!
Oh, Ulalaka wants to talk to me.
Wait, but is there any new quest?
No, no new quest.
Don't worry.
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
Did you see that?
I sweeped!
You're still doing your part to revitalize the village.
I greatly appreciate it.
I can feel my divinity returning to me.
Let me grant you my blessing here.
Level 3!
Now support's up to 8.
Wait, how long?
8?
You mean there's only 6 people here before?
Oh, I can have 65 decorations.
And consign villagers to mining.
Into the mines you go.
Oh, I can have them farm for me!
That's right.
Yay!
Delegations!
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
In the words of a certain police detective, great vegetables.
Alright.
Then, you can make your villagers into farmers from the villagers' menu.
Those assigned a farmer will perform 3 key tasks.
Find any seed you own in open fields, water crops, and harvest fully grown crops and place them in the shipping shed.
Oh, nice.
Yay, delegation!
Okay, and then you can have them chop wood.
Oh, if they deforest everything, the loggers will venture outside.
Alright, nice.
Let's hope the goblins don't get them.
And then, what's the mining?
Villagers assigned, can collect material stone and ore for you.
All materials will go to the storage box.
How wonderfully inspiring.
What is it?
Oh, pardon me.
I got ahead of myself.
I'm just so moved by your work.
To think you will build houses and grow our population so fast.
Wait, there are more people already?
Why?
Well...
The wind must have carried tales of your efforts to the eyes and ears of those who would return.
That was fast!
If we continue to restore the village, people will surely come blocking to it.
Yeah.
Guess that means we best get to work.
My God.
That old village chief should have retired earlier, guys.
Look at me.
I was village chief for one day.
And I already fixed everything.
Your kindness truly know no bounds.
Well...
Actually, I find myself thinking I had to...
I made it home so good.
I had to reward your kindness.
So early this morning, I gathered all the villagers and asked them to offer you...
Aw, I just wanted your help.
Oh, la la call.
Hooray!
To my surprise, I hardly needed to ask.
They all have been waiting for such an opportunity.
Wow!
Wow, that's good news!
Indeed.
So you need assistance with your crops?
Then the villagers are here to help.
Hohoho!
And that's all.
Should you require lumber or stone?
Then they can help with that as well.
Farewell.
Now, shall we ask for their aid?
Yes.
Delegation!
It's time!
I love delegation!
Wait, move villages?
Oh yeah, I just have one.
Uh, you know what?
We need more trees.
Okay, there we go.
Farm, farm, farm tree.
This would make the life a whole lot easier.
Thank you very much.
Thank you so much, Ulalaka.
It's my, it's my pleasure.
Mm-hmm.
Though we may have some trouble if our population grows too large.
Did you say something?
What?
No, not a word.
Farewell.
Once again, you have my thanks.
Now you'll excuse me.
Hmm.
Am I imagining things or does she still have something on her mind just now?
No, she definitely did.
And I want to know what.
Come on, let's go talk to Ulalaka one more time.
Okay, wait, but it's his birthday.
Let me wish him a happy birthday.
To introduce myself, my name is Murasame.
I seek to become the world's greatest swordsman.
I'm always happy...
Happy birthday, man!
Did you like my, the swimsuit I got you?
Hmm.
Sometimes I fail to detect Sir Sakaki's prisons.
There's more to them than meets the eye.
It's your birth...
Happy birthday, buddy.
Right.
And what is it?
Happy birthday.
It's your birthday.
Want me to dance?
Are you happy?
He doesn't appreciate me.
This is why...
This is why I went for the waifus.
They appreciate my dance...
Oh, it's tomorrow.
Sorry, I can't read.
Oh, hey!
Hey, Hina!
Sorry.
I'm really bad with reading comprehension.
English is my first language, guys.
I can't be the only one who envies the people here, right?
I mean, just imagine and enjoy the cherry blossoms whenever you wanted.
All right.
Okay.
Ulalaka is hiding something.
You can tell me anything.
Oh, look at them.
Yay!
Delegation!
I don't have to do actual farming now.
Let's go!
Oh!
I didn't expect to see you both again so soon.
Hey!
Be honest with us here.
Is something still bothering you?
Well...
Well, yes.
I must handle some things on my own.
Gotta love them.
Don't give us that.
We're friends, right?
Let us help.
And we can be more than friends if you want.
Ulalaka.
Oh, you too?
I tell the truth.
That's happy.
Wait.
I can have a child, right?
Oh my god!
Wait, I can have a child with the goddess?
As happy as I am to see our village grow.
Oh my god!
My child will be so strong!
We all know demigods are one of the strongest out there!
Our harvest can hardly feed the current population.
Everyone...
I literally harvested 70 turnips.
Everyone is working.
We have eight villagers.
What do you...
No, we have four!
We have four villagers!
What do you mean we don't have enough crops?
Our hate for...
hunger to be the only reward.
Gotcha!
I can see why that worry you.
Leave it to me!
We're gonna have the potato diet, guys.
But leave it to us!
If there's any job that the descendant of a legendary dragon and an earth dancer can't handle...
This is it!
You'll do this for me?
Right.
Of course!
My thanks.
Oh, how wonderful!
I don't know how to thank you!
Farewell.
You'll be doing this village a great service!
It costs code every day to...
What?
These expenses come...
I have turnips!
Why are you...
Excuse me!
Um...
This is a turnip diet right now?
Like...
And since you're the chief, village assets in your pocket are one and the same.
Yet insufficient funds are not able to pay the village's happiness will drop.
Ask villagers directly if they have any...
How dare you!
How can they not appreciate my turnip diet?
Ireland was so happy about potatoes.
It's not like there was a fat in it or anything.
To receive personal requests.
Completing these will grant your rewards and also raise your bond level with requesters.
Alright.
What was your request?
Seeing your fate at this early hour is a good omen, my little bird.
Oh my god.
She broke the fourth wall.
Plenty seemed pleased as well.
Oh my god.
She's actually talking to me, guys.
Do you have any requests?
I ask for your help with something.
Plenty more fields in the dev zone.
Oh, okay.
You have my gratitude.
Uh...
We'll need more fields.
All good.
The villagers can take care of planning great.
We just need to give them a place to do that.
She knows.
She broke the fourth wall just to talk to me.
Whoops.
You didn't see that.
You didn't see that, guys.
Okay.
I need to talk to Woobly.
Okay, we need terrain files.
And we need two more.
Yo, guys.
You didn't see that.
It was a love shot.
It's like Cupid chat.
Okay, I'm good.
And then building menu.
Okay.
Place.
And then...
I'll place one here.
Yes!
And then...
My people can...
I've delegated it to my people.
I completed your personal request.
Yay!
I got bamboo.
Nature's grace.
Nice.
You work swiftly.
I see earth dancers are not to be underestimated.
Don't forget me.
Yes.
I would never, Lord Woobly.
My thanks.
Thank you both very much.
I hope I might be more of an assistant to you.
But all I can offer is the building recipe.
Yes, yes.
But it's your building recipe.
You're too humble.
This is more than enough.
I appreciate your kindness.
Oh, I can make a blacksmith.
Okay.
What's that?
Curiosity seems to have gotten better of you, Suzu.
Much like it has with me.
Hey there, you two.
Interesting.
Some sort of blacksmithing blueprint?
I take it?
Wow.
Wow, you can tell with just one look?
You learn a lot when you travel the world.
You sure do.
But what are we going to do about proper blacksmith to run the place?
Hmm?
You don't want to have one here in the village?
Aww.
We do.
Or we did.
No one's seen...
And no one tried to find him?
Ha ha ha ha.
No one's seen Kihachi.
Okay.
I think some of these missing villagers aren't villagers that moved out.
Like, I think they're actually missing, missing.
People are growing concerned.
A healer's family has been searching for him.
In fact, rumor has it he was seen transforming into a strange red oni in the spring highlands.
Say what?
Stop it, Mario.
No more scary stories.
Me dispiace.
And that's a theory.
A game theory.
I'm only sharing what I've heard.
Or say we look into the blacksmith thing.
We could use some decent weapons after all.
Oh, okay.
So now we got the blacksmith mission.
Oh my gosh.
There's so much to do here.
I hear like this this game you can play it's like a very, very, very, very, very long play time.
So like you're basically getting like you know your money's worth.
Oh yeah, you can upgrade your weapons.
Yay!
Wait, I need to chop this too.
I want to get more seeds for my delegated workers.
Yeah, definitely like a lot of time you can invest in it.
Because like there's so many different elements.
Like farming, RPG, fighting.
I like the combat.
I think the combat's really fun.
Especially like I think like like the charge attack.
Like when I did the boss fight I really, really liked the boss fight for that.
Because it was fun.
And I'd be like drum.
30 hours in and still not close to finishing.
Yeah, so like and even after like the main storyline like you got there's like other stuff you can do as well.
Because there's like several villages you can micromanage as well.
Because this isn't the only village here.
So yeah, and then like different types of crops and everything.
But I had a great time!
I had a really great time checking this out.
A huge thank you to RuneFactory for sponsoring me.
But yeah guys if you want to check more of the content make sure to click on the link pinned in the chat in the description below.
But I had a great time I'll say thank you again to RuneFactory for sponsoring me and letting me experience RuneFactory for the very first time like as a blind reaction.
Like I never I never played their series before so it was definitely very enjoyable.
I I personally love playing farming games.
Um love farming games off stream.
Um sometimes when I just want to relax and everything.
And um it has definitely been a very enjoyable experience.
But yeah huge shout out to them again.
Um but yeah thank you.
I think it's definitely very beginner friendly.
Like as someone that has not played this before it's very easy to pick up and as well as the mechanics and everything.
Um but yeah thank you guys.
I'm gonna call it here everyone.
Uh like I said please click on the link in the description and pin in the chat.
It does help out the stream a lot.
And it does support the game as well.
So thank you Room Factory.
Um as always everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and we're out to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me head to bed cause you deserve it.
I'm gonna head off now.
I'm a little EP and I didn't get a lot of sleep today.
I didn't get a lot of sleep today so I'm gonna go head off.
Yes!
Work for me villagers!
Work!
I love delegation!
I definitely enjoyed the weapons and talking to all my waifus and the never ending beach episode.
The beach episode that lasts forever.
But yeah, apparently there are four villages there too.
So like there's spring, autumn, summer and winter village that you can unlock.
Uh but um so there's so much playability there.
Anyway guys I'll see you later everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!